après le point presse du rhdp le parti
au pouvoir hier soir l'opposition
peaufine sa stratégie pour l'après
scrutin une conférence de presse s'est
tenue ici à la résidence de l'ancien
président ivoirien henri konan-bédié du
pdc y une conférence de presse menée par
pascal affi n'guessan du un leader d'une
frange de f pays se sont pas parmi les
quatre candidats en lice sont les deux
qui n'ont pas voté hier lors du premier
tour de la présidentielle ivoirienne
déclarations il rejette élections
dénonce une violation de la constitution
des irrégularités lors du scrutin et
appelle à l'ouverture d'une transition
civile
par ailleurs pascal affi n'guessan a
aussi a précisé que le mandat d'alassane
dramane ouattara a pris fin hier à
minuit techniquement c'est la réalité
on les écoute pascal affi n'guessan les
bars des membres de l'opposition appelle
à l'ouverture d'une transition civile
afin de créer les conditions d'une
élection présidentielle juste
transparente et inclusive
les partis et regroupements politiques
de l'opposition appellent dès cet
instant à la mobilisation est générale
les d'ivoire et les ivoiriens et
particulièrement toutes les forces vives
de la nation les démocrates épris de
justice et de paix au faire barrage à la
dictature et à l'afev d'une présence on
assiste donc à une véritable un
véritable bras de fer l'opposition a
donc tenu ce point presse alors que la
commission électorale indépendante doit
cet après-midi commencé à dévoiler les
résultats provisoires département par
département comme les autorités il faut
savoir qu elle minimise l'impact des
daims des incidents d'hier sur le bon
déroulement du scrutin et sur le
dépouillement qui est toujours en cours
c'est ce qu'on nous a précisé hier au
siège de la commission électorale sur la
situation
eh bien on sait que dans le nord tout
s'est bien déroulé hier en revanche le
sud du pays a été fortement perturbé de
nombreuses régions ont été empêchés de
voter
d'ailleurs la situation à lier encore
très tendue on note des barrages et des
manifestations il y aurait plusieurs
morts à l'intérieur du pays aujourd'hui
pascal affi n'guessan tout à l'heure lui
a évoqué une trentaine de morts ce qui
ferait en tout 110 morts depuis
l'annnonce de la candidature d'alassane
dramane ouattara
des chiffres donc de l'opposition à
prendre avec des pincettes là pour le
pouvoir et l'opposition donc la guerre
de communication elle ne fait que
commencer
le camp d'alassane ouattara doit
maintenant montrer que les incidents
d'hier n'entache pas à la crédibilité du
scrutin
pour les populations ordre est donné de
circuler le moins possible dans tout le
pays
c'est le cas également à abidjan où des
incidents ont fait au moins un mort hier
à yopougon une commune populaire de la
capitale économique
les résultats ils devraient être
dévoilés d'ici 48 heures selon les dires
de la commission électorale indépendante
ici en côte d'ivoire